eric the enemy not a good conversation
for him shut out again and on one of the
i think it was one of the uh playoff
game
pre-game shows i said that eric b enemy
has resigned himself
to the fact that he's not getting a head
coaching job this cycle and he's telling
people that he's just fine waiting for
the perfect opportunity
i don't know when the perfect
opportunity is going to come if no
opportunity
is coming for him now three years as the
coordinator of the andy reed
offense as coach dungey joked yesterday
on football pod in america
you know the headline may be andy reid
has lost his touch because he's
got a long history of hiring
coordinators who become head coaches
hey andy what's wrong you hired a
coordinator who's not good enough to
become a head coach
you hired the wrong guy apparently i i
mean i i'm
dumbfounded i don't get it i don't i
really don't
you know it's you look at i know andy
reid's there
but you look at what he's done you know
with a young quarterback
with some personalities that aren't
always easy to deal with there in kansas
city not that they're bad but we've seen
you know
little incidents here and there we've
seen him push
travis kelsey on the sideline or kelsey
yell at him all those type of things
he handles it you know with gold stars
anytime you see an nfl films thing and
he's micked on the sideline
i love the way he talks you look at the
offense
and i know andy reid is there but it's
evolved over the last few years too
it's it's changed we it was bobby bombs
away and patrick mahomes throwing bombs
everywhere
and the whole every defensive football
started to go whoa let's back up
and now they have this offense we
watched the other night in the afc
championship game where
fine we could still throw over 350 yards
and we don't even have to throw a ball
past 10 yards
i mean he threw like one or two balls
past 15 or 20 yards the whole game
so he he's ahead of the curve he's an
outside the box thinker he's creative
i don't get the eric me enemy thing i
mean you and i have heard some of the
same rumors about him being raw and just
not as political that way
but that's that's it it's still it's
amazing to me
we are just two years removed from the
running gag
being if you've ever ridden an elevator
with sean mcvay
you're a head coaching candidate in the
nfl you think about what eric the enemy
has been an
integral part of for the last three
years one of the greatest offenses we've
ever
seen he's been right in the thick of it
working with those players learning how
to deploy
weapons in an effective way dealing with
the challenges
of when do you ever hear
a member of the chief's offense
complaining that's
i know not getting the ball in right
right i know
and eric the enemy's part of the
structure that keeps that from happening
exactly i know that's why it's it's i
it's amazing to me it really is and and
you know
obviously some of the guys that come out
underneath
you know andy reed peterson nagy this
has been more impressive than than those
guys as far as what he's done on the
offensive side of the ball
you know that's where it just it seems
odd i can't believe it i really can't i
thought this year for sure was the year
for eric b enemy
um but we're gonna wait till next year
yeah i i uh i don't get it and
i even like this past i was just like
look what i'm doing right now like look
what they're doing in the games right
now like again
you know i go back and watch that film a
little deeper like the last two days
for my podcast yesterday you know pass
protection is an issue like we've talked
about right both tackles are hurt right
now
it's four to their five starting linemen
from the start of the year aren't there
you know they don't blink at eye they
don't even hear about it
and and then they reorganize their
offense then again to go
okay we don't have great protection
we'll find a million different ways to
make it to where our o-line doesn't
really have to protect protect in the
traditional sense
let's sprint him out this way and sprint
him out that way
and sprint him out this way and throw it
back this way and let's get underneath
the center and run play action pass
because that slows down the pass rush
that that's where i'm just i'm amazed i
don't know how you can't watch kansas
city film
and see this guy talk and the way he
manages people on the sidelines and just
go
i want this guy like this guy looks like
he's a head coach and knows how to talk
to people and knows offense that's
that's that's where i'm amazed
and the people who just shrug and say
well it's patrick mahomes it's not just
patrick mahomes it's not hey patrick go
make something happen go draw something
up in the dirt in the huddle
you have to take full advantage of that
special weapon and use it the right way
and that's what the chiefs have done
it's all about maximizing
the skills and abilities right players
you have yes they have a highly skilled
player
but still eric the enemy has helped
maximize the skills and abilities he has
here's my theory my and this is just
basic billionaire privilege mentality
i think that the nfl's owners don't
like the idea that a bunch of
us are trying to tell them what to do
i feel like at some level there's
natural resistance
to it and this is a basic aspect of
human nature sometimes
we don't like people telling us what to
do and i think the more
money and influence and power we acquire
we reside in that bubble of sure i'll
figure out what's right for me i don't
need you telling me what to do and the
last thing i'm going to do is create
the impression that i surrendered to the
mob
i'm not surrendering to the mob that's
saying hi
hire eric the enemy now well maybe i
mean i i don't doubt that some of that
goes on
with some of the owners definitely um
you know and the other thing too
which is which is interesting because
we're talking about david culley and his
lack of
you know being a politician to get these
type of jobs
you know be enemies like that too he's
he's just a real football coach
i don't ever hear any stories from
anybody i know in football about the
enemy
angling himself or he's been trying to
do this or that
or anything like that which i would
think is even more of a badge and honor
to
to hire a guy like that's the kind of
guy you want to be your head coach
he's not into that bullcrap nonsense he
just wants to coach football
um and and but mike i don't i don't
disagree with you i think there's a lot
of factors here but uh none of them make
sense to me
and and the fundamental problem is most
of these owners
are making the decision with input from
individuals who are more inclined
to play the game with people who play
the game yeah that's right right
right that's that's right that's the
thing that
that keeps the owners from realizing
this is who i need to hire yeah
because the owner hires a guy
in your front office right yeah right
the owner you've got politicians in your
front office who who are looking for
other politicians who are of the same
political mindset
have the same agent have the same
connections understand how to
mutually scratch each other's backs
that's that's where i think
it's hard for someone like eric the
enemy david cully bruce erin's mike
zimmer to crack through
because the people who are close to the
owner are playing that game
and the owner doesn't quite realize that
they're the ones who are being deprived
of great coaching candidates because
there's this broader game that's playing
out yeah
i don't disagree with that as part of
the politics of football i mean politics
have become very big in football
it's a very political league now it
transforms i want to say somewhere where
i feel like 15 16 years ago i i can
remember
just certain people going man you know
like my
my playing career oh this league's not
the same as when your dad's here
man a lot of things have changed oh you
know those type of things and it's just
part of the game now
and it's unfortunate it really is hey i
saw my buddy kyle shanahan
you know him do a lot of great things on
the offensive side of the ball
he was not a political guy at all he
wasn't going to call and do anything
and it took like just a year of
unbelievable offense and
quarterback who's not really an mvp
caliber off
mvp caliber quarterback to have that
year and everyone whoa
he's kind of good maybe we should hire
him as a head coach what
he was good the seven years before that
too it just
i don't know what how to hit you in the
face there it just goes on in the nfl
sometimes and there is
there's too many political connections
and loopholes and
people who are connected that way and
there's only 32 coaching jobs only 32 gm
jobs and a certain number of these
executive vp
slash whatever the title is to allow the
person
to take credit when things go well and
avoid all blame when things go
poorly the jack easter bee position is
what we'll just call it from now on and
that
all undermines and dilutes the ability
of the owner to make good decisions and
it's fun
it's fun for us it gives us things to
really
sink our teeth into other than our
opponent's kneecaps
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports